I mean darling I just would never ever
have predicted this
I mean onion was down to the last 1010
and there was some serious competition
but I just never for a moment thought oh
sorry that must be James paladin olives
well though next to the artichoke hearts
where they always are the package is
absolutely fabulous I mean it's almost
double what I'm on now but you know me
darling it's not about that it's more to
do with the fact that I've always wanted
to work in a place where it goes beyond
the surface you know but it's not just
about me being an attractive young woman
it's not just about the double first
from Oxford it's not just about the
famous judge father it's about me about
what I'm really truly capable of
what company she bring to this company
the headquarters are in Mayfair but
which is fine but they have got branches
in New York and also Seoul it's not the
West Coast darling I know but sometimes
you just got to take the rough with the
smooth I mean it did not go down well
with Dermott & Co and to be honest it
was quite embarrassing because they were
just chucking all these offers at me
being like you want us to double the
package do you want a new office do you
want to travel more and I'm like no guys
I love you and I'm sorry but sometimes
you just gotta move on in life and for
me that times now okay gorgeous so nice
to see you promise me you'll come and
see us in Suffolk we just have the
tennis courts resurfaced they are fab
and I know James would love a rematch
why I see you right
you
you